In the world of
application performance,
you hear us talk
a lot about the 60
frames per second and
16-millisecond barriers.
But have you ever stopped to ask
why those numbers are relevant?
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and if you're
a developer who's serious
about performance,
this is the type of technical
minutia that's worth knowing.
Now, let's take a step back and
understand that most of this
has to do with hardware,
human hardware.
See, the human eye
doesn't act like a camera.
There's no snapshot of the
world that gets sent over
to the brain to make
sure that you don't run
into that new piece of
furniture in your living room.
Instead, the brain
is continuously
processing visual signals
that the eye is sending to it.
There's no concept of frame
or snapshots in this regard.
Our concept of motion that
comes from still frames
is effectively a hack.
See, by displaying
images fast enough,
we can trick the human
brain into perceiving motion
where there actually isn't any.
The caveat here is that how
fast we display those images has
a large effect on how fluid
the motion will actually
look to us.
See, at a minimum, you
need about 10 to 12 frames
per second before
the human brain
starts to perceive
motion from a flip book.
However, it doesn't
actually look that smooth.
24 frames per second allows the
human eye to see fluid motion,
but that's only thanks to visual
effects like motion blurring.
And by the way, 24
frames per second
is a sweet spot for
the film industry
since it's fast
enough to show motion,
but cheap enough to produce
for films on a budget, which
is why, for the past 50 years,
most of the movies you see
are displaying at 24
frames per second.
Now, 30 frames per second
is enough for movies.
But without the fancy
cinematic effects,
it's actually not
that convincing.
While 60 frames per second
is actually the sweet spot.
Great, smooth motion
without all the tricks.
And most humans can't
perceive the benefits
of going higher
than this number.
Now, it's worth noting that the
human eye is very discerning
when it comes to inconsistencies
in these frame rates.
For example, if you're moving
along at 60 frames per second,
and then you suddenly drop
to 20 frames per second
every now and
again, the human eye
will see this lack
of smoothness.
This tends to cause lots
of tension and uneasiness
for your users.
As an app developer,
your goal is clear.
Keep your app at 60
frames per second.
And then keep it there
through the duration
of the user's
experience with it.
Now, what 60 frames per second
means for you as a developer
is that you've got 16
milliseconds per frame
to do all of your work.
That is input, computing,
network, and rendering,
every frame to stay
fluid for your users.
You can't argue with this.
The math says so.
And there's an entire
boatload of issues
that can cause
your frame to take
longer than 16 milliseconds.
To find those problems
and fix them right,
make sure you check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns content.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]